[Music]
season 20 a Big Brother let's run down
all the houseguests okay and I want to
get your thoughts on their gameplay so
far and what they need to do okay and
let's start with Caitlin Caitlin needs
to get her emotions in check and stop
having such a thin skin easier said than
done
I like literally can't deal with this
I'm like I just I can't maybe rather
than lash out bite your tongue sometimes
swaggy C arrogant but interesting to
watch you know he thinks he's like king
of the house like what more do I have to
do like I come in I went to competitions
I give you the first showmance at a
summer like what more do I gotta do
I think his ego is gonna get the best
opinion and cost him the game ultimately
Bailey I like to watch her because she's
real and she's emotional and she is
outspoken and in a showmance I'd like
hurt her look and her big mouth you to
sit down and be humble alright Sam Sam
very likeable and sympathetic and good
at competitions as we saw in the POV I
think her biggest challenge will be
bonding socially she might say something
that someone who has a thin skin will
pick the wrong wave like hey I'm
literally just telling everybody to tell
me what they think about it that's it
okay well that's what I think about it
the end Scotty he reminds me a little
bit of Steve who won a few seasons back
he's a little bit the odd man out yeah
he's more than a little bit of the odd
man out
so social game is non-existent
they don't dislike him but they don't
like him they're gonna use him for his
four numbers for our votes the big
question is well Scotty got his first
kiss in the Big Brother house no Tyler
he's the one to watch I think he is
playing a really smart game and there's
a likable guy and the biggest thing he
has going for him is that he doesn't
talk too much he's just like a neutral
likable guy he does what he has to do
and he's just gonna I think keep making
it week after week after week I love you
right now I'm losing my mind
Vesey I like him I like that he and
Haley are connecting on a romantic level
you know they think they like each other
he's definitely easy on the eyes he's
very cute he's a good sport and he I
like that he was offended that he was
the least trending person because now he
has reason to kind of step up his game
Haley Haley is sweet she is a little bit
naive I feel but something tells me it
takes a lot to get her mad at you but if
you push the wrong buttons then you
gonna see her come to life other than
that I think she's just kind of a sweet
innocent
rock star I like her I think she's one
to watch in that I don't just gonna make
any enemies
I think she's Earth's mom a very likable
but she probably needs to win a
competition or two I don't see her
winning any but you know how do you tell
someone step up your your game and win
competition
thanks for keeping you need yogurt Brett
he is very interesting to watch he's a
big personality another one who suffers
from high self esteem which I don't mind
he's smart I think he can probably be a
little bit on the obnoxious side I see
him getting into like a heated argument
someone Winston he's a little dull to me
Winston is land you know I mean he's a
good-looking guy he has an amazing body
I don't think it's a bad guy but I don't
think he's the most dynamic personality
in the house Angela Angela well she's a
fierce competitor she needs to stop a
per social game and expand and be nicer
to people who are not in our alliance
all right Rachel Rachel is a little bit
in your face not the most likable person
she's physically fit so I think she can
do well at competitions I don't know I
think there's something kind of catty
about her it feels like I'm being judged
which has happened a lot through my life
Casey I like her I don't I don't know if
her eyes seem very kind I think she's a
good kid and Big Brother is the only
show she watches on TV oh really yeah
say no I liked her yeah she has a
sweetness of her aura is sweet she seems
like a good person JC Oh JC is like no
one I've ever seen before
he seems like a party boy he seems like
he's well-liked
I think his he's overthinking the game
it'd be kind of alone right now
except for that final two he has with
Tyler that Tyler has what that means
nothing that means nothing until it has
to for him yes
Steve Steve oh poor Steve by a vote of 7
to 6
Steve you are evicted from the Big
Brother house well that'll do it for our
first thoughts on season 20 of Big
Brother not everyone that was everybody
all 16 of them
[Music]
[Applause]